did you guys learn anything from working
with each other what was like a fly on
the wall moment that you guys can give
me about each other
um well
i i feel like
i feel like i learned so many things
working with melanie
i think she's
a genius and
just one of these incredible incredible
people number one amazing human number
two amazing
uh artist but i think the thing i
remember most about working
with you mel is
your ability to be so still
and so powerful
at the same time i find i find working
with her like watching this channel
happening i
totally agree with that
okay melanie what was one thing that
surprised you or you took away from
working with jessica
well i've been a fan of hers for years
and years and i think that she's been so
underrated because people don't want to
believe that you can look like that and
be as talented as she is
and i really think that this one is the
one that everyone's just going to be
like
she's she's one of our great actors
she's one of the greatest actors i've
ever worked with
she was like honestly
how are you going to make me cry stop it
thank you you have so much to celebrate
speaking of celebration jessica you just
had a birthday i did i did yes tell us
everything what did you do what was the
scene set the stage
okay
well
i i actually
thought nothing was happening i thought
we were gonna
my husband and i were planning something
for the summer and
and then
he completely surprised me
with
a incred with an incredible party with
my friends
um from montana where we were at the
time and
um
he flew his band in and he played
for me he played my kids maybe that cake
and these beautiful cards and then he he
played this whole show for me all covers
um like sort of the songs of our life
together all the songs that we love and
have been listening to
for the last gosh we've been together
for 14 years or 15 years or something
now and married for almost 10.
it was so amazing and it was such a good
surprise and i i love surprises so he
knows that about me i love it he played
covers of the soundtracks of your lives
and melanie
your husband like is just jason ritter
he's so wonderful he's an incredible
actor he seems like the most wonderful
person i've met him a few times
and you guys seem like you love each
other so much it's ridiculous i
we do we do love each other so much i
can't deny it i'm so glad and happy that
both of you are crushing it in life and
in the show you're both on fire
[Music]